I didn't have it last year you didn't
have a last year no I'm having it next
year let me ask you something so yeah
for sure so I don't think so do you
think bigger maybe I think it's thick
no the weight it's not a weight thing I
just think it's thick have you seen it
so you never seen Eric's pain no it's
not one of those guys he's not one of
those guys that you can I don't like
seven I have a very shallow vagina
that's not gonna work I need smaller
okay I'm right now I mean not not as in
a girlfriend I don't know what about
that opera singer you were dating an
opera singer no I was dating a girl that
was on prod with like it that's my
singer oh yeah what happened it icon yes
we broke up yeah yeah doing her thing I
can't imagine what your taste is like
now what was this taste before from what
you saw
let me to me he would be like you know
and he's an average guy probably got
girls that were but now he has ever been
quantity over quality guy ever and yeah
I know you're a quality guy so I can't
imagine whatever lasted in like hooking
up with a girl just because she would
hook up with me like right you need the
insides to insides are important
sometimes Bobby on tinder oh my god I
can't I still can't believe it myself
remember when I would start texting you
right when I started posting pictures of
her I'm like does that girl need help
like do I need to call the police yeah
are you holding her against her will you
don't find me that I may as I find you
charming but I don't think that I'm
attractive
uh you're not my type if I was gay no I
mean if I was I think I wouldn't bone
you yeah that's why I was gay I would
probably go yeah it took this guy's dick
well that's you and me
how about this if you were gay and I was
gay would you at least invite me to
parties and stuff like we'd be yeah yeah
but I would do a real big blanket like
hey this is my friend Bobby and you
would probably never recommend me to
your other gay friends yeah I would
guys that were into you know fat Asians
I don't think you're fat oh that's a
nice thing yeah yeah well this would be
friends in that world yeah uh I remember
one time when I was shopping like with a
friend of mine at Northshore Matt and I
was trying some stuff on this was before
modern family or anything and we're
trying I was trying some clothes on and
I came out and my friend Matt was like
dude this the salesman totally thinks
were a couple I was like oh really he's
like yeah and so I go back in and I and
I try a couple other things off our
track other couple things on and I come
out and the salesman is so clearly like
flirting with Matt like flirting with it
yeah
and I find myself like getting really
like mad about it
because he told me that he thought we
were a couple so then I'm like well if
he thinks we're a couple like this is
really disrespectful today when we
finish up and we're walking away he's
like dude that guy totally totally was
hitting on me and basically asked me to
go out I'm like I want to go back and
we're not gay but you know my god it was
he didn't find you attractive well he
wanted to bone that man yeah do you find
that let me cuz you do okay I have seen
a couple of modern families and I know
you've won Emmys mm-hm
and people have said to me like you know
that guy I go yeah is he gay
and I go because you're so good on that
show as that guy is that weird out there
or now it was in the beginning a little
bit but do people ask you that all the
time yeah I block anybody on it I love
blocking people on social media so
anybody that says are you gay in real
life I just block them cuz I think
that's a completely inappropriate
well yeah yeah yeah it's like if I was
your the person I'm gonna come out to
yeah I know what thank you so much for
asking me Instagram
[ __ ] off yeah [ __ ] off yeah you're not
it's not an okay questions but in the
beginning it was weird because you know
like I never wanted to seem like I was
ashamed of being gay so like if I wanted
to talk to a girl I couldn't go up to a
girl me like hey just so you know I'm
not gay and I think you're really cute
like I would never say that because that
would imply that I would care if you
thought I was that there was something
wrong with being gay yeah it was a
little bit of a you know you're right
that I am an average you know guy and it
was a deeper hole that I already had to
kind of dig myself out of because I'm
funny and charming and it takes a minute
for that to wash over a girl they're not
just deciding that I want to bone that
guy purely based on his looks
yeah so I had a little bit more of a
challenge in the beginning but I
overcame it I'm so [ __ ] happy for you
are we done no I just wanted to say that
oh but I think that I like sort of gay
guys I mean like I like men with a
little bit yeah I like salut inna di I
find that attractive yeah I and the
point is is I'm I'm confident enough of
a man in my masculinity did not care if
a girl thing exactly I think he knows
that it means Eric looks so angry
everyone right in high school yeah and
why was younger I mean I don't think
there's a soul that he doesn't want to
tell that story to I think I did
it's freeing to talk about it
[Music]